[Musique]
15h30 berlin le bunker de la
chancellerie et là dans un de ces
couloirs de béton que l'on traverse sous
la terre là à 15 mètres sous la terre un
homme attend cet homme-là n'est pas
grand angle et trapu avec un coût et
paie une phase peu intelligente l'aide
même banale des cheveux noir collé en
arrière et très souvent ses cheveux
les caresses de la main des grosses
mains vulgaire aux doigts boudinés est
cet homme qui a tancé martin bormann le
second d'hitler
celui qu'on appelait les mines ans brune
hitler lui la plaie mind sfinks mons
sphinx et il attend parce que là
derrière la porte
son maître h/f de mourir
hitler s'est retiré avec eva braun seule
dans son appartement et là dans le
couloir borma l'attend avec d'autres
avec goebel savez klingel valet de
chambre avec axe man chef des jeunesses
hitlériennes avec green ch
l'aide de camp dit claire et tout à coup
à travers la porte un coup de feu un
seul on attend un quart d'heure c'est le
délai exigé
et puis on ouvre la porte c'est le
valais qui entre le premier ling est un
peu plus tard bormann qui voit là sur le
canapé de cadavres eva braun celle qui
est depuis quelques heures madame hitler
puisque hitler l'a épousée qui est morte
en l'avalant sa capsule de cyanure et
hitler lui qui a préféré d'un coup de
revolver se faire sauter la tête
gorman keim cas le chauffeur d'hitler
d'autres vont emporter les cadavres dans
le jardin de la chancellerie et là vous
le savez on les brûle rats avec le peu
d'essence qu'on a pu trouver ils
brûleront mal et puis on les enterre
rats dans un trou d'obus mais déjà tout
cela pour boorman c'est le passé parce
que après la mort d'hitler le 30 avril
martin bormann va vivre la journée sans
doute la plus extraordinaire de son
existence je dis bien une journée car là
tout à coup il va être seuls 100 m et ce
sera lui le maître
il a fallu la mort d'hitler mais il est
arrivé pour quelques heures au pouvoir
suprême
alors comment cela s'est-il fait vous
savez que la faire barman est un mystère
c'est une énigme
mais ça n'est pas seulement une énigme
eux qui est une sorte de jeu d'esprit
disons comme louis 17 mois je me suis
beaucoup passionné vos louis 17 mai oui
17 et bien oui c'est un jeu ça n'a
aucune importance
tandis que de se pencher sur le mystère
de boorman cela permet de réfléchir sur
un certain nombre de choses et d'abord
sur l'histoire qui a permis un homme
comme normal justement d'arriver là où
il est alors qui est il seul homme
il est né en 1900 c'est le fils d'un
employé des postes toute petite
bourgeoisie
à la fin de la guerre 14-18 y les
canonniers milieu peu de temps quelques
mois démobilisé l'amertume de la défaite
bien sûr comme tous les jeunes de son
âge comme la plupart d'ailleurs des
démobilisés et vie l'engagement tout de
suite il va militer dans l'association
contre la prédominance de la juiverie en
allemagne vous voyez que tout de même
déjà y suit une voie
et puis aussi dans les groupes pro ce
bar qui sont également des associations
anti sémite d'abord et puis nationaliste
ensuite et c'est justement dans un des
groupes rossbach qu'il va participer à
la mort d'un homme qui s'appelle k-dow
qui est accusé d'avoir collaboré avec
les français oui les français occupent
alors cet homme accusé d'avoir collaboré
on l'emmène dans un voyons la somme
d'abord à coups de bâton et puis ensuite
on les gorges on le tue on arrêtera les
auteurs de l'assassinât
le principal c'est un homme qui
s'appelle rudolf hoess je dis bien eux
c'est non pas s à ne pas confondre avec
rudolf hess mais ce rudolf hoess aura
lui aussi un avenir
il deviendra le commandant du camp
d'auschwitz voyez comme les choses se
dessinent
bormann lui n'a pas agi directement
quand on étudie sa participation à cet
assassinat on s'aperçoit qu'il a
organisés qu'ils étaient là derrière
qu'il a bien d'ailleurs avec une sorte
d'art prévu le moment où on attaquera
cet homme ou on n'en mènerait comment le
tueur est second ferait ensuite et c'est
pour ça qu'il ne condamn ait que comme
complice à un an de prison tout de même
il fait alors de prison assortis de
prison c'est la découverte
il y à cette époque-là déjà un agitateur
un homme qui s'appelle adolf hitler et
qui va de ville en ville
quelquefois de boer hambourg qui monte
sur une estrade il un petit imperméable
mie2i fait des discours il dit des tas
de choses que l'allemagne n'a pas été
réellement vaincu que elle a été trahie
et que les allemands vont retrouver leur
fierté et barman qui est à ce moment-là
régisseur de ferme n'a pas
d'instructions dans man il a été
jusqu'en troisième classe et puis alors
tout de suite au travail à la ferme par
majette écouter cet agitateur et sur le
champ il croit en lui
il a la foi et on comprendrait pas
normal voyez vous si on ne savait pas
qu'il a la foi une foi qui ne s'éteindra
jamais une fois totalement les clés
il fait tout pour approcher plaît et il
devient l'un des compagnons là des
hommes qui se battent pour hitler quand
il le faut et alors on lui confie des
responsabilités dans le tout jeune parti
nazi et des responsabilités de plus en
plus grands bientôt il sera l'un des
chefs du service de presse notamment de
sorte que quand ils se marient en 1929 à
cette époque là le parti nazi est déjà
très important et bien quand ils se
marient en 1929 avec une jeune fille de
20 ans qui s'appelle gerda bourg la
fille n'a commandant qui est lui-même
peut-être plus encore
national-socialiste que norman et bien
c'est hitler qui est son témoin et ils
iront ensemble à la mairie dans la tempe
et d'olic
1933 et bien c'est l'heure du
national-socialisme hitler prend le
pouvoir et c'est naturellement aussi
leur de martin norman parce que hitler
au pouvoir va désigner comme son
représentant direct auprès du parti
comme l'interprète de sa pensée comme
son second va désigner rudolf hess un
aviateur un as de la guerre 14 18 un
nazi de la première heure lui aussi et
se ruent dans les faits ce qui est
investi de pouvoirs considérables aura
comme chef d'état major qui est bien
martin bormann et désormais il est en
place et cette place il la quittera plus
parce que paraît ce qui est toujours au
près dit claire bormann est lui aussi
auprès unités il n'est que par personne
interposée bien sûr mais sans but et ce
but qu'il va suivre avec une sorte de
ténacité fantastique
une obstination qu'on peut lire
d'ailleurs sur son visage
eh bien son but c'est d'être sans
intermédiaire auprès dit qu il est
bientôt pourquoi pas bien parce qu es
mon dieu
bien sûr est un nazi metz est un
aviateur
alors de temps en temps il aime bien
aller reprendre les commandes de 101 que
ça lui fait plaisir
vous êtes un sportif alors il aime bien
l'hiver aller faire du ski dans les
alpes bavaroises lors hitler dit commun
même coin qu'on l'appelle rudolf hess
il est pas là ma une fibre mais martin
bormann est là et oui parce que barman
lui l'est toujours
c'est à force c'est sa force
extraordinaire car il va devenir au fil
des années l'inséparable
celui qu'on trouvera toujours prédit
clair avant 41 et encore bien plus après
que 1941 quand idole fès fera son
entreprise que vous connaissez cette
folle entreprise de partir de s'envoler
pour l'angleterre proposer la paix alors
maintenant le secrétaire du führer
fatalement c'est bormann qui remplace
rudolf hess et hook à hitler bormann le
suit au front à l'armée bormann est là
avec les diplomates bord mal avec les
ministres norman et c'est même une
hantise pour ceux qui accompagnent est
clair pour ceux qui servit clair parce
que s'aperçoivent que tout à coup il y
as entre eux et hitler un barrage et ce
barrage s'appelle boorman on peut plus
voir hitler sans s'adresser à bormes et
même quand les compagnons les plus
intimes goebbels par exemple parle avec
heatley et bien tout à coup la porte
s'ouvre c'est bormann qui
miraculeusement à par hasard oublier un
papier et des hommes comme bell
s'exaspère car norman finira par être
hays aussi bien parc de belz et puis par
himmler à qu'il fait peur et oui faire
peur et müller et puis par goering tu
prends des colères terribles et qui à
nuremberg dira ah si jamais il était
avec moi ici dans ma cellule je
l'étrangleur est détesté aïe
mais il est là mais alors qu'est ce que
ckac roi à quoi sert-il à quoi croit-il
eh bien d'abord il sert parce que il
interprète les ordres d'hitler et plus
les années passent et plus cette
interprétation est personnelle parce que
hitler fini par lancer une idée un désir
un souhait et boorman traduit et norman
réalise sur le papier les ordres partent
les circulaires partie signé norman et
on réalise alors boorman par exemple ces
l'anéantissement des élites en pologne
délibéré c'est en ukraine les mesures
délibéré également de rigueur féroce les
prisonniers qui tombent entre les mains
des allemands et vous savez que dans les
débuts l'ukraine il y avait en ukraine
une certaine opposition qui depuis les
débuts l'union soviétique n'avait jamais
réellement cessé le sort ce que on ne
craignent plus qu'ailleurs les allemands
ont trouvé des gens n'ont pas prêt à se
rallier mais dont dix ans la défense
était moins ardente qu'ailleurs et 1 d
homme d'état digne de ce nom aurait
profité de ce mouvement
citant de centaines de milliers de
prisonniers sont faits dans les premiers
temps mais assez peut-être justement
parce qu en ukraine moins qu'ailleurs on
est fanatique du régime soviétique et
pour répondre à cette possibilité
immense que d'autres perçoivent très
bien au tour dix plaies que fait boorman
il ordonne la rigueur et la rigueur dans
la bouche de boorman
vous savez ce que ça peut vouloir d
alors ces prisonniers qui se rendait
bien d'abord on les nourrit pas il
arrive dans les camps à moitié mort est
d'ailleurs la moitié sont en chemin
et puis ceux qui sont là on les parque
comme des bêtes féroces et boorman l'a
dit comme des bêtes féroces et puis en
ukraine même la population est traitée
comme une race inférieure des esclaves
tout ça sur les ordres de ben main
bormann prescrit plus de vaccination
jamais attention une épidémie c'est
souhaitable
pourquoi bien parce que moins il y aura
d'ukrainiens plus il y aura de place
pour les allemands qui vont venir créer
là des colonies c'est ça le but alors
également ont prescrit des produits
contraceptifs qui sont en vente partout
l'avortement légalisé il s'agit de
diminuer la population
alors voilà boorman et puis bord ban
s'est encore oui une hypothèse à propos
de l'ukraine certains ont été jusqu'à
dire et même écrire et notamment le
général gehlen chef des services secrets
allemands que barman était bien
peut-être un agent soviétique
et oui parce que avec ces mesures il
était le créateur de la résistance bien
entendu tout ça n'est pas très sérieux
mais cela montre ce qu'étaient les
mesures de boorman épi boorman c'est
encore la solution finale de la question
juive
et oui encore born alors il avait lu
mein kampf attentivement avec l'
attention scrupuleuse qu'il mettait à
tout fait et dans mein kampf il avait
découvert la nécessité d'une lutte sur
trois fronts il fallait attendre à
anéantir les juifs les slaves et les
chrétiens ça faisait beaucoup de monde
et avec la même force de frappe lente
il a essayé et s'il nous est pas arrivé
à ses fins c'est parce que le destin n'a
pas volu mes les ravages qu'il a pu
faire son immense voile à bord
quelquefois certains s'adresser et
rarement parce qu'on avait peur de
vendre et on s'adressait à heatley et on
lui disait m'enfin mein führer pourquoi
il est médiocre
il est bête et puis enfin ce qu'il fait
est exactement ce qu'il faut faire et
leurs épaules et m'écouter quand je
demande un rapport à quelqu'un d'autre
on m'apporte 20 pages
je mets une heure à lire j'y comprends
rien je demande un rapport à boorman il
m'apporte une par jeu mais cinq minutes
allaient à l'aller
je comprends tu vois là il avait une
mémoire colossal immense il se souvenait
de tout ce qui pouvait passer dans la
chancellerie du reich il le savait il
connaissait les dossiers le connaissait
les hommes
il était indispensable en même temps
cet homme avait une vie privée sa femme
gerda qui l'adoré qu'il admire et
presque autant keatley lui avait donné
neuf enfants
et si elle n'y avait pas donné plus
d'enfants c'est qu'elle ne pouvait pas
parce qu'elle admirait tant qu'elle se
disait le sens de boorman doit
évidemment essaimé dans la patrie
allemande alors il faut beaucoup de
petits boorman et piwi mais qu'est ce
que vous voulez la nature et la de 1929
à 1944 neuf enfants un enfant tous les
18 mois de prêt ne pouvait pas faire la
montre lors normal était très ennuyée
et puis un jour l'idée
gerda avait une amie sa meilleure amie
qui s'appelait magna behrens une
charmante jeune comédienne est normal
s'est dit que voilà la solution et un
jour il a adressé une lettre à sa femme
les lettres existe on les a retrouvés
pour l'édification de la postérité
l'histoire la lettre est ainsi conçu ma
chérie mon aimé voilà quel bonheur
c'est fait et oui magnette et sa
maîtresse et il voulait en informer
immédiatement sa femme qui lui a répondu
on a la lettre à mon chéri quelle chance
quel bonheur magna est une femme
charmante c'est vraiment celle qu'il te
convenait alors maintenant vite qu'elle
soit enceinte et elle a même les idées
précises sur la question parce que elle
lui écrit arrange toi pour que nous
soyons désormais enceinte
alternativement de manière à ce que
toujours à ce que tu es toujours une
femme disponible elle aura même des
idées plus précises encore parce que
tout ça s'organise très bien tout le
monde vit ensemble on est très heureux
et elle trouve que c'est dommage que
magna n'est pas pu épouser boorman c'est
injuste alors gerda préparera une loi
sur le rétablissent
la polygamie pour les dignes aux têtes
les dignitaires nationaux socialistes
le texte sera préparé par barman est
semble-t-il hitler n'a pas voulu signer
tout de même voilà ces gens voilà ce
qu'ils sont voilà ces gens qui tournent
autour de ce maître centrale qui est qui
et hitler voilà ces gens qui sont là
comme dans la termitière les termites
tourne autour du roi ou la reine des
termites et puis cette guerre cette
guerre qui inéluctablement va vers sa
défaite et bons mâles lui s'occupe de
rien parce que il a ses fonctions et ses
fonctions c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
alors il va jusqu'au bout la guerre cela
faire des militaires lui il a à faire
assurer le triomphe de la doctrine
malheur à ceux qui s'en écartent alors
il sera là bien sûr après le complot du
20 juillet pour réprimer et la
répression vous savez ce qu'elle a été
atroce
et puis ces officiers de la wehrmacht
qu'on a jetée en prison pour un soupçon
est bien à mesure que l'on s'achemine
vers la conclusion il décide qu'il ne
faut pas qu'ils survivent et dans les
dernières semaines de l'histoire du
reich en avril 45 il fera tuer ces
officiers de la wehrmacht et puis aussi
c'est lui qui donne les derniers ordres
les plus terribles
il est la terre et en 45 dans le bunker
où vont le rejoindre successivement
d'ailleurs hitler goebbels et les siens
général creps chef d'état major et puis
d'autres encore ra bon bien sûr et il
envoie ses ordres l'ordre par exemple si
jamais un drapeau blanc apparaît à une
fenêtre il y a en effet à mesure que les
soviétiques avant sur berlin des gens
qui scinde drapeau blanc dix ans on ne
nous fera pas de mal alors maintenant
malheur à ceux qui ont hissé un drapeau
blanc les ss entre chez eux et fusils
tous les habitants de la maison du sexe
masculin ordre de boorman
l'ordre d'anéantir toutes les industries
normal l'ordre d'anéantir tous les
dépôts de vivres normal bormann voudrait
lancer légal les énormes réserves de gaz
qui existe en allemagne
malheureusement les alliés avance trop
vite il n'a pas le temps mais il a le
temps de donner l'ordre car c'est lui
d'ouvrir les vannes de lâche près qui
s'engouffre dans les tunnels du métro de
berlin et kinois bien sûr quelques
soviétique qui avançaient par là mais
aussi 30000 berlinois car les stations
de métro servent d'abri et d'hôpitaux
mais peu lui importe parce que là alors
que les soviétiques sont déjà dans
berlin
bormann croit à la victoire finale il le
croit parce que nous le savons par des
témoignages irréfutables
certains par exemple il y avait des
aviateurs qui étaient là celui du monde
quand même dans ses couloirs de
brouckerque d'ailleurs plusieurs bunkers
bancaire dss le bunker d'hitler et pis
les réserves à côté des employés alors y
avait des aviateurs c'était la nuit et
barman à vous le voyez trapu toujours
dans son uniforme ss solide et il voit
ses aviateurs ces jeunes aviateurs
il les regarde avec un bon sourire et
leur dit vous vous êtes des fidèles des
vrais mais après la victoire vous aurez
des récompenses qui dépasseront tous vos
rêves
nous sommes le 25 avril 1945 berlin est
entièrement investie par les soviétiques
les américains les anglais les français
font ce au delà de l'elbe il n'y a plus
rien en ahl
il parle de la victoire pourquoi bien
parce qu hitler croit encore à la
possibilité d'une victoire parce qu
hitler a dit où seront vainqueurs
l'armée funk viendra nous délivre une
armée qui n'existe plus qu'un barman
exécute norman va jusqu'aux et bien sûr
tout s'arrête quand
il faut que cela s'arrête l'armée veut
qu'on apprend qu'elle n'existe plus que
les soviétiques seront là demain après
demain ou plus tard éclair avoue qu'il a
perdu la guerre il annonce que se donne
la mort et se donne la mort le 30 avril
mais il a rédigé son testament et dans
son testament il indique que ben man est
le plus fidèle de ses serviteurs avec de
belles s'il est en tête de liste
il remercie barman et il fait lui son
exécuteur testamentaire et en même temps
le ministre du parti chargé d'assurer le
triomphe de sa doctrine et oui exécuteur
testamentaire et barman se sent tout à
coup investi d'un pouvoir moral autant
que physique qui le comble et savez-vous
à mon avis ce qui est peut-être
l'épisode le plus étonnant de guerre
c'est que boorman pendant 24 se refuse à
annoncer au monde la mort d'hitler et
oui le bunker continue à communiquer
avec le monde par la radio pour le
téléphone et pendant 24 heures bormann
qui devrait avertir de nits la grande le
grand amiral dennis de ski est là bas au
nord à flensbourg dans la petite partie
d'allemagne qui subsistent encore
il devrait l'avertir c'est normal de
nice le successeur a été désigné par
hitler il ne fait pas c'est exactement
le lendemain 15h30 vous voyez 24 heures
qu'il s'adresse par mais sage adonix en
lui annonçant la mort d'hitler et en lui
annonçant que lui boorman va tenter de
rejoindre de nix attention de touche ont
très exactement au coeur du problème au
noeud du problème parce que maintenant
nous allons essayer de savoir ce qu'est
devenu normal nous l'avons vu se camper
devant nous nous l'avons vu vivre nous
l'avons vu penser mais maintenant nous
allons le voir se perdre pour nous
et nous allons peut-être essayer de leur
trouver de le rechercher
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe bourque 24
heures il annonce adonix son arrivée il
a essayé vaguement d'obtenir des
soviétiques un sauf conduit les
soviétiques l'ont bien entendu envoyé
promener exigeant la reddition sans
condition il annonce à ceux qui sont là
encore dans le bunker qu'il faut partir
ils partiront pendant la nuit du 1er au
2 go belz lui a préféré vous le savez se
tuer avec sa femme et ses six enfants
et voilà que dans la nuit exactement
entre 11h et 2h30 du matin des petits
groupes successifs quitte le bunker et
boorman part au milieu de la nuit avec
quelques-uns il y à l' axe man chef de
la jeunesse hitlérienne lier la camca le
chauffeur d'hitler il y à la chaume fait
guère le médecin de bunkers et puis
alors neumann un ministre pichery
germann l'adjoint de gaube lcp betts
également l'un des pilotes d'hitler et
ces gens vont quitter la chancellerie
par un itinéraire que je vais vous
montrer
voilà la chancellerie est en pleine nuit
ils s'enfoncent d'ambert est d'abord une
s'enfonce dans le métro parce que bien
entendu n'est pas question assez dans
cette ville où déjà sont les russes
alors donc ils s'enfoncent dans le métro
et vont suivre très exactement cette
ligne aussi que la ligne du métro
parce que bien entendu il n'y a plus
d'électricité à berlin depuis longtemps
berlin est une ville en ruine et dans se
mettront peut avancer
à la lueur de lampes de poche et fo moi
je les imagine ces gens là spa qui avant
cela ils sont souvent en uniforme ss les
lampes de poche sur les rails c'est pas
qui résonnent sous les voûtes et il
avance normale a décidé qu'on sortirait
ici à la station de banhof
friedrichstrasse c'est à dire la gare de
friedrich tu as la rue de frédéric et
ils sortent et ce qu'ils voient est
abominable épouvantable effrayant c'est
cette ville qui brûlent elle brûle
entièrement cette ville alors ce sont
les flammes dans la nuit
et puis cette terre et les nappes de
fumée on est on est pris à la gorge
ils les explosions sans arrêt les
soviétiques inom toute cette zone d'obus
et de bombes
certains d'ailleurs des fuyards de
bunkers redescendront dans le métro et
repartiront ils n'osent pas tellement
c'est effrayant mais normal lui décide
d'aller vers le nord à pied alors il
emprunte la friedrichstrasse voici ici
d'ailleurs un agrandissement
vous le voyez de cette petite somme qui
était là et voici donc la
friedrichstrasse et si lâche près qui
est le fleuve de berlin ici un pont qui
est le pont de weiden dames c'est à dire
levaï dan dah marge brute que le but de
norman et ses amis ils sont cinq ou six
c'est de monter par là et il s'avance en
effet et s'aperçoivent avant d'arriver
au pot qu'il ya ici un barrage de fils
de fer
ici il est indiqué seulement aux
extrémités mais en fait ce barrage s'est
vu film de fer barbelé bar entièrement
la fois des strass impossible d'aller
plus loin
alors il décide pas conséquent qu'ils
vont repartir lorsque miracle trois
tanks trois temps qui arrive
il ya donc encore des tanks il ya donc
encore de l'essence et
peut-être les trois derniers est
immédiatement gorman se fait connaître
alors on ne sait pas très bien parce que
les témoignages différencie des montées
dans un tank sur un tank ou bien si la
marche est derrière ce temps comme un
fantassin qui montent à l'assaut enfin
avec ses amis sont avancés avec cet
angle qui ont naturellement martelé
briser les fils de fer se sont avancés
tout allait très bien lorsqu'un obus un
obus tiré de plein fouet a fait exploser
le tank sur lequel se trouvait bon alors
là nous avons évidemment des témoignages
et c'est là que le problème se nouent en
fait le chauffeur m k qui est légèrement
blessé et tour dit aveuglé dit il se
relève il s'en va et il témoignera plus
tard j'ai vu boorman mort à côté du
normal et m il viendra dire 'ça y
viendra prononcer ce témoignage au
tribunal de new york
est-ce que c'était vrai en fait tous ces
gens qui se sent qu'ils ont été
commotionnés blessé c'est la nuit
n'oublions pas son parti sauf tout au
moins le médecin stumpf et guerre
bormann étendue soit disant mort et puis
axe man le chef des jeunesses
hitlériennes et cheveux garde est en
fait axe mal lui se relève un peu
titubant et voit moorman se relever à
côté de lui normale n'était pas marrant
comprendre la méprise de kenka on
compense dans témoignages il a cru qu'il
était mort mais non l'autre été étourdi
et se sont ou seront lus alors il n'est
plus question d'aller plus loin et
boorman et les autres repartent par ici
par la ligne du métro jusqu'à la gare de
l'erba nov
et là ils vont se disperser il y a deux
groupes axe man et cheveux germann qui
décide de partir par ici et il y a
stumpf et guéret bormann qui décide de
partir pas ackman s'en va est séparé un
moment donné de choix germann mais il
revient seul parce qu'il ya un barrage
il ne peut pas aller plus loin il
revient là et là racontera-t-il et bien
il a vu deux cadavres par terre ils les
vues raconte il al'allure de la lune et
des explosions
et ce sont les cadavres de stocker et de
boorman
c'est le témoignage que axe man
apportera aux américains qu'ils
arrêteront un peu plus tard quand il
aura quitté berne alors
esque axe man a raison est ce qu'il a vu
le cadavre de bornes
il faut dire que après sa libération par
les américains axe man dira qui n'est
plus très sûre d'avoir vu boorman
c'était la nuit là l'une des explosions
s'est pas beaucoup et depuis axe man est
beaucoup moins formelle alors est-ce que
boorman a été tué là non parce qu'un
autre témoin le colonialisme sst bourse
youth qui était sorti du bunker à peu
près dans le même temps que moorman leur
trouve un peu plus tard dans la nuit
dans un hôtel l'hôtel atlas et bord mal
à changer de vêtements il est en civil
changer de vêtements pourquoi comment
vous savez berlin c'est le plus grand
vestiaire du monde à l'époque pour avoir
un costume à sa taille on se penche
il ya suffisamment de cadavres pour ça
et d'ailleurs dans les jours qui
suivront un travailleurs des usines
solex un français dont le prénom est
maurice originaire du havre à porter un
manteau de cuir noir qui l'a trouvé et
dans ce manteau il y avait un carnet
avec le nom de boorman ce carnet a été
remis aux autorités soviétiques et je
sais de source certaine que ce carnet
est actuellement dans les archives
soviétiques alors ce maurice on aimerait
bien le connaître la revue stern a lancé
un appel
on n'a pas retrouvé ce maurice peut-être
que la revue interne et moins lui au
havre que la télévision est écouté et
regardé
alors si jamais ce maurice nous regarde
j'aimerais qu'ils se fassent connaître
car il aurait des choses à dire en tout
cas ce manteau de cuir
ce carnet au nom de boorman démontre
quand l'effet boorman à changer de
vêtements et tiburce youth va passer une
partie de la nuit avec lui et tiburcio
ce ne quittera seulement à l'aube alors
que norman déclare qu'il va partir pour
le nord pour flensbourg car il a
toujours cette idée
french bourg le nord de l'inde alors
maintenant nous avons une série de
témoignages car nous avons perdu
est normal à partir de ce moment là
alors pendant les années qui suivront
vous savez vous relisez vos journaux
alors de temps en temps par le barman
alors tantôt c'est un moine dans un
couvent de rome ou s'aperçoit qu'il sait
pas du tout ça on en arrête de temps en
temps en amérique du sud on s'aperçoit
que c'est un brave commerçants qui n'est
pas du tout normal alors on le trouve en
australie on trouve en suisse on trouve
même à berlin c'est pas très prudent
on le trouve même en egypte aux côtés de
farouk ça paraît bien bizarre il est en
iran il mène la résistance contre le
chah ce qui paraît également fort
étrange tout ça n'est pas sérieux ça
procure les titres à sensation
c'est pas ça qui nous intéresse alors il
faut chercher parmi d'autres témoins et
le premier qui réellement semble sérieux
est celui d'un écrivain qui s'appelle
heinrich l'inao et qui connaissait
l'homme et qu'il a vu à flensbourg à
nous y sommes dans la seconde partie du
mois de juin 1945 la chronologie est
avec nous la géographie ou et puis il y
à un résistant italien qui un peu plus
tard il s'appelle luigi silvestri et lui
aussi a vu précédemment boorman il voit
un homme qui entre dans un couvent du
tyrol il reconnaît bornes il ne peut pas
malheureusement le rejoint et puis il ya
encore beaucoup mieux
il y a à bolzano une enquête d'un
britannique qui s'appelle trêve hors
pair et qui a fait des enquêtes
remarquable sur les derniers temps
d'hitler et du nazisme est très fort au
père qui voulait en 45 retrouver bormann
qui croyaient à la survie de boorman eh
bien tu rêves vos repères va à bolzano
parce que gerda bande sa maison de
l'oberzalsberg ayant été démolie s'est
enfui avec cette exodes d'allemands qui
ont couru à chacun chacun tantôt elle
s'est enfuie avec ses enfants et elle
s'est réfugiée à bolzano et dans le
courant de l'été 45
elle a été prise de malaise
elle s'est fait examiner on lui a dit
qu'elle avait un cancer alors il est
allé se faire soigner dans un camp de
personnes déplacées qui était à côté à
merano dans un hôpital un hôpital
militaire et rêveur père se disait mais
oui il aime tant sa famille bormann que
s'il est vivant ou le retrouvera parlent
et ils rencontrent en effet à bolzano
une femme qui lui raconte une histoire
singulier cette femme c'est la veuve
d'un médecin israélite qui a quitté
l'allemagne au moment des persécutions
et qui avait soigné la famille boorman
avant et cette femme racontera traver
père écoute et voilà il ya quelques
semaines at elle raconte sa la faim de
je me promenais j'étais dans la rue
j'allais faire mes courses et j'ai vu un
homme arrivait en face de moi j'ai
reconnu boorman il m'a regardé d'un air
terrifié et rhj rock et puis le parti en
courant je les ai suivis il s'est
engouffré dans une maison s'est perdu
dans des escaliers je suis monté
derrière lui il y avait des tas de deux
portes
j'ai pas pu le retrouver [ __ ] art fair
lady mais enfin madame sans blessure de
votre a fait il paraît que tout le monde
a son sosie vous savez il dit mais
monsieur prévost ropert si c'est un
sosie pourquoi s'est il enfui en voyant
c'était très fort il ya beaucoup mieux
encore il ya une journaliste de grand
talent qui s'appelle dominique auclair
qui est une spécialiste éminente de
l'europe centrale et qui souvent dans
ces pays et qui a retrouvé les familles
qui ont élevé les enfants dorment
parce que quand gerda est morte en 46
elle a confié ses enfants un prêtre
catholique et en même temps elle a nommé
ce prêtre tuteur et elle a reçu les
sacrements de l'extrême onction orge
erdan
nazis fanatiques quelques mois encore
auparavant écrivait des lettres à son
mari pour lui dire il faut poursuivre
les chrétiens il faut les pourchasser et
même dans la liaison avec magna elle
n'avait qu'un doute d'une réticence est
maniaque
encore un but de superstition chrétienne
et tout à coup cette femme qui change
et d'abord les barmans était protestant
avant d'être nazi et qui se convertit et
qui confie ses enfants un prêtre
catholique en étant sûr donc ils seront
catholique et d'ailleurs ils le sont
tellement que l'aîné adolphe addow le
filleul dû plaire se fera peut être
pourquoi alors on pense aux témoignages
de luigi silvestri le couvent on pense à
ce que nous savons sur cette chaîne de
couvents et c'est vrai qui a facilité
l'évasion de grands nazis et des chemins
en particulier
doit-on leur reprocher à ces moines il
faut savoir se rappeler que quelques
mois auparavant c'étaient des juifs
qu'il cachait alors oui il y a eu cette
chaîne de cours et admettons que gerda
ai vus arriver son mari qui lui dit ce
sens des couvents qui m'ont sauvé et
tout à coup elle se dit alors quoi ces
chrétiens que j'ai pour chasser ils ont
sauvé mon mari et pour peu qu'un prêtre
était là un prêtre qui sut lui parler et
d'été là on comprend mieux cette
conversion alors voilà donc cette piste
cette piste qui se renouent en amérique
du sud il ya un trou parce que en 47 un
allemand a nommé s line qui a connu
bormann qui est en amérique du sud leur
voix mêmes scènes qu à bolzano
c'est dans une forêt en argentine et il
voit boorman est normal qu est à cheval
tout à coup en le voyant ses frais
galope pour fait voilà à peu près tout
ce que nous avions lorsque des
informations beaucoup plus précises nous
ont permis de cerner la piste de boorman
à une époque relativement récente
et d'abord c'est d'un témoignage de
michel barroso a requis dans une longue
enquête qui l'a publié sous le titre les
vengeurs raconte que norman a pu
réellement aller à flensburg ensuite
dans une ambulance il a pu gagner le
tyrol de la s'étant arrêté auprès de sa
femme et de ses enfants à bolzano
il a gagné gêne puis l'espagne et là
j'ai personnellement enregistré un
témoignage important celui d'un
ecclésiastique de haut rang qui a
beaucoup connu les affaires espagnole
pendant la dernière guerre et qui m'a
affirmé à moi je sais où étaient boorman
pendant son passage par l'espagne de là
ils s'embarquent semble-t-il en 47 sur
un cargo italien pour l'amérique du sud
voilà ce que raconte bar zohar qui
recueillait asuncion au paraguay un
témoignage à mon avis de grande valeur
c'est celui d'un médecin qui s'appelle
bis qui est d'origine autrichienne le
docteur bis en 1959 a été appelé au
chevet d'un homme qui était fort mal and
un allemand et cet homme il a soigné la
guérit et il a regardé les photos qu'il
avait le barman
il jure que cette énorme jusque là voyez
vous ce sont des gens qui croient avoir
et ça ne vous convainc peut-être pas
comme moi non plus ça ne me convainquent
pas entièrement faut quand même rappeler
que les commandos israéliens qui ont
arrêté un eichmann ont déclaré avec
force la piste deichmann nous a fait
croiser celle de boorman il faut
rappeler que le fils deichmann a juré
que norman était vivant il faut rappeler
que le frère de boorman lui même est
sûre de son frère était vivant il faut
rappeler que le procureur de prusse de
as plus tôt le procureur général 2s
messieurs fritz power mettait appris en
1966 pour cent mille marque la tête de
boorman preuve qu'il croyait qu'il était
vivant mais enfin tout ça
peut-être n'est pas entièrement
convaincu mais en 1968 le sunday times
publié un article dans tenue terry qui
est un journaliste spécialisé dans les
affaires d'europe centrale c'est le seul
de times et le supplément du dimanche du
times qui n'est pas précisément un
journal le pour médine est sérieux le
times et anthony terry publié
l'interview extrêmement apporte c'était
celui d'un allemand erich karl vite
valdes lequel déclaré paisiblement
tranquillement acteurs et j'ai vécu de
longues années avec boorman en amérique
du sud alors terry se demander si
c'était vrai il le croyait il a écrit je
me suis posé la question de la véracité
j'y crois qu'ils croient parce que cet
homme est très malade cet homme un
concert de la gorce c'était en 68 il ne
demande pas d'argent est renommé ou pas
ça lui est égal il parle parce que il
est amer parce que des 45
il a sauvé barman dans la bataille de
berlin c'est lui qui lui a permis de
passer cinq jours dans la banlieue chez
son oncle et ensuite ayant rejoint
boorman
il a vécu dans une colonie à la
frontière du brésil et du paraguay
la colonie wagner et même voyez-vous
terry faisait le dessin faisait le
dessin de cette colonne la voix 6 jamais
on a donné un témoignage aussi précis à
témoignages aussi détaillés
voici le brésil le paraguay et ici sur
ce cours d'eau qui s'appelle le riz
oparanya il y à une colonie qui
s'appelle la colonie waldner 555 voix là
regardez bien car c'est ici affirme vite
valdes que se trouvait boorman encore en
norman ayant suivi cet itinéraire que je
dépeignait boorman réfugiés avec des
nazis fanatiques un immense domaine
protégé par la forêt d'une part cette
forêt impénétrable cette forêt
inexpugnables où se trouvent des indiens
qui sont d'ailleurs à la solde de
boorman
de l'autre un cours d'eau qui a dix
mille de l'arche
il est là il y a huit bâtiments une
immense cour carrée un bâtiment en dur
pour moorman et puis au bout de la piste
toujours de piper club de petit avion
prêt à s'envoler en cas de danger est là
boorman vie jusqu'au jour où son ami son
fidèle vite valdes malades désire mourir
chez lui et lui demande de l'argent pour
s'établir en allemagne et boorman refuse
malheur vite valdes rentrer et amer
parle
anthony terry pourquoi pas anthony terry
est sûre du témoignage de vie de valdes
et j'estime pour mon compte que ces
témoignages peut être réglée alors vite
valdes donne d'autres détails
bormann à un revenu mensuel de 200 mille
francs actuels c'est à dire 20 millions
d'anciens francs et un capital à sa
disposition la fortune d'hitler et le
trésor de ss c'est à dire 63 milliards
d'anciens francs
bormann visiblement est à l'abri de tout
rien ne pourrait plus le menacé puisque
cette information en 1968 aussi précises
qui aurait permis de repérer boorman n'a
été suivie d'aucune intervention de
quiconque
alors vous vous dites qui on cherche des
leçons dans l'histoire
holliday bien oui c'est pas brillant
c'est probablement le plus mauvais de
tous celui à qui on ne peut trouver
aucune excuse et c'est celui-là qui a le
plus de crimes sur les mains c'est celui
là qui est vivant les autres sont morts
on les a pendu à nu rabais très vrai
on peut se dire ça mais on peut aussi se
dire autre chose c'est que ça fait
beaucoup d'années ça fait 25 ans cet
homme là qu'on nous dépeint allant au
début de ville en ville fuyant devant
les commandos se terrant changement de
résidence
arrivant là si ces deux avions sont
toujours prêts à partir j'imagine et
pourquoi ça fait 25 ans que cet homme là
a peur c'est finalement à côté des
quelques secondes que dure la
strangulation 25 ans à avoir peur
c'est peut-être une justice comme les
autres
[Musique]